[Musica]
qualche anno fa un americano warren be
nice
alla domanda quanti dipendenti avrebbe
avuto la fabbrica del futuro
lui rispose che ne avrebbe avuti due un
uomo e un cane sostanzialmente l'unico
compito dell'uomo era dar da mangiare al
cane e il cane doveva sorvegliare che
l'uomo non toccasse il robot che avrebbe
sostituito integralmente la macchina io
faccio il sindacalista sono il
segretario dei metalmeccanici della cisl
e mi sto battendo contro questa immagine
perché una delle più grandi malattie di
questo tempo è un pessimismo che sta
ammantando un po tutti soprattutto
riguardo al futuro del lavoro
in realtà funziona
in realtà è la tecnologia a volte non
non assiste come in realtà se noi
guardiamo la storia dell'umanità gli
indicatori sociali e democratici fino al
1784 sono sostanzialmente piatti la
prima il primo balzo in avanti
dell'umanità viene proprio con la
macchina a vapore le macchine arrivano
nella produzione e grazie alle macchine
si superano i limiti muscular muscolari
degli esseri umani e degli animali nel
lavoro questo cambia il mondo è il primo
balzo in avanti perché le città si
inurbano diventano gigantesche cambia si
trasforma sostanzialmente il lavoro si
passa dall'agricoltura all'industria e
appunto il superamento ai limiti della
forza fisica dell'essere umano grazie
alle macchine
oggi siamo di fronte al secondo balzo in
avanti dell'umanità perché questo
superamento sarà dato dal dalle macchine
dalle macchine volute dalle macchine
benfanti che consentiranno di superare
alcuni limiti cognitivi degli esseri
umani
qual è il tema fondamentale è che il
grande cambiamento a cui stiamo
assistendo e soprattutto molto più
rapido in termini di velocità quando fu
inventata l'energia elettrica impiego
circa 40 anni per diffondersi nelle aree
più ricche del pianeta oggi una nuova
tecnologia abilitante si diffonde in
poche settimane anche nelle zone più
povere del mondo
allora qual è il dibattito oggi nel
mondo la tecnologia va a velocità
logaritmica cosa fare bloccare la
tecnologia e il progresso
questa è la cosa più stupida nella
storia dell'umanità nessuno ha mai vinto
una battaglia contro il progresso la
vera cosa da fare e potenziare gli
esseri umani fare in modo che la
formazione l'educazione l'istruzione
siano rafforzate molto di più e diventi
in un elemento noi diciamo un diritto
soggettivo lunga tutta la vita delle
persone
cos'è questa rivoluzione innanzitutto è
fondamentale capire cosa non è
non è la dematerializzazione
dell'economia chi dice che non ci sarà
più la manifattura racconta delle bufale
chi pensa che sarà mera robotizzazione o
automazione sbaglia qui avete uno dei
gioielli dell'italia della lira quella
di cui ci vantiamo sempre l'italia che
faceva le svalutazioni competitive pur
di mantenere dei prodotti non di alta
qualità mentre il resto dell'industria
europea puntava sulla qualità già nel
1978 veniva prodotta questa macchina che
si chiamava fiat ritmo in uno
stabilimento a sud di roma cassino ed
era completamente robotizzato
automatizzato per cui i robot sono tra
di noi da più di 30 anni e questa paura
degli umanoidi dei robot è assolutamente
un tema piuttosto ridicolo
e ovvio che i robot di nuova generazione
cooperativi non sono i robot della
fabbrica fordista in serie ma questa
grande rivoluzione non è un'opzione
si può scegliere quale è la ricetta qual
è la strada più giusta per ogni comunità
e per ogni paese ma non si può restarne
fuori
noi in questa fase gli accordi per far
rientrare le produzioni in italia si
sono basati proprio su l'impiego di
nuove tecnologie grazie a nuove
tecnologie abbiamo guadagnato in
produttività abbiamo avuto la
possibilità di riportare con quello che
si chiama risciò ring back produzioni
che erano andate in paesi a più basso
costo e le abbiamo riportate nel nostro
paese
ovviamente la manifattura ritorna
centrale ma ritorna centrale non isolata
non in un'oasi con attorno nulla
in una fabbrica che diventa
fortissimamente integrata al suo interno
le macchine parlano con le macchine con
internet of things e le macchine
dialogano con l'uomo in questa
ibridazione che spesso fa paura perché
abbiamo sempre bisogno di qualche cosa
che ci spaventi in realtà basta avere
andare in ferrari e vedere quando si
monta il motore v12 l'ibridazione che
c'è tra il robot cooperativo e il
ragazzo altamente specializzato fa
vedere che in realtà il robot
cooperativo toglie delle parti
ripetitive e meno utili meno cognitive
del lavoro dell'essere umano ma il tema
fondamentale sarà l'ecosistema cioè
tutto ciò che c'è sostanzialmente
attorno all'azienda una fabbrica
intelligente non funziona se non ci sono
lavoratori professionalizzati al suo
interno ma non funziona se attorno non
c'è un ecosistema intelligente pubblica
amministrazione smart mobilità smart
produzione dell'energia di rete non
concentrata in grandissimi luoghi dove
si produce e non si diffonde questa
possibilità e sistemi di mobilità smart
senza queste cose sarà assolutamente
complicato avere una smart ha
funzionante questo per far vedere gli ho
scritto un libro anche che è quello che
si vede all'inizio che sostanzialmente
un manuale di resistenza la tecnofobia
perché cosa spiegano tutti gli studiosi
tecnofobi che vanno molto forte in
questa fase
se noi prendiamo una fiat uno la fiat
una impiegava la proporzione mille
lavoratori la fiat punto cento se la
riflessione resta tutta lì e si ferma lì
come fanno anche molti studiosi
addirittura di oxford e ovvio che uno
dice vedete già lo diceva john maynard
keynes c'è disoccupazione tecnologica ma
questo è niente di più falso perché nel
passaggio tra la fiat uno e l'api
appunto a parità di meccanica dentro
l'automobile aumenta tantissimo
l'elettronica il software e aumenta
ancora di più l'ecosistema attorno al
veicolo di mobilità e aumentano i
servizi industriali per cui c'è una
compensazione dei lavoratori che servono
in meno nell'assemblaggio dell'auto
gli altri aspetti che sono attorno se
noi andiamo avanti arriviamo a tesla che
è quella sotto questo discorso va
ampliato e amplificato ancora di più
come compensazione sostituzione e
cambiamento del lavoro quello che dico
sostanzialmente è che il beat ancora per
molti anni e io penso secoli profumerà
ancora di olio motore di olio idraulico
questa cosa che non esisterà più
l'economia quella realizzata anche con
le mani e con la robotica è una fake
news
se dobbiamo essere tecnofobi e noi in
italia siamo uno dei paesi più tecnofobi
del mondo
come sapete in italia il tv a colori è
arrivato quindici anni dopo il resto
d'europa nel 72 fu minacciato il secondo
governo o il terzo non ricordo bene
andreotti da il partito repubblicano
da queste parti era fortissimo una volta
il partito repubblicano di far cadere il
governo se avesse accelerato
nell'introduzione della tv a colori
pensate che clima che discussioni
all'inizio degli anni settanta in italy
arrivava il segnale della tv a colori ma
non avevamo gli apparecchi per poterlo
leggere e pensate da dove arrivava
arrivava da capodistria per cui capite
bene che chiari tardi abbiamo io dico
sempre se siamo tecnofobi se la
tecnologia se accettiamo che la
tecnologia e guardiamo solo la parte di
distruzione che paghi vecchie mansioni
dobbiamo tornare qui a sinistra mi scuso
con le donne presenti perché sono tre
donne che guidano un aratro perché già
nel passaggio con la guida dei buoi ci
sono tre disoccupati
questo è ovviamente un modo
assolutamente assurdo da quando diciamo
che la tecnologia è in qualche modo
destructive sull'occupazione in realtà
non è così quello che sostengo è che non
è la tecnologia distruggere i posti di
lavoro è la mancanza di tecnologia che
distrugge posti di lavoro e se andiamo
nella storia del nostro paese qui a
sinistra c'è il settore degli
elettrodomestici bianco le prime
delocalizzazione avvennero alla fine
degli anni 80 proprio perché in pessimi
i cambi generazionali padre e figlio
alla guida delle imprese cosa accade si
iniziò a di
gestire in tecnologia e partirono le
prime delocalizzazioni industriali
chiusure di stabilimenti verso altri
paesi non solo a salari più bassi ma
anche a tecnologie più avanzate
un elemento fondamentale che sostiene la
mia tesi è che i paesi più hi tech del
mondo ovvero quelli con la densità di
robot installate per ogni dipendente
maggiore sono i paesi a più bassa
disoccupazione corea del sud giappone
hanno il livello di disoccupazione più
basso del mondo e hanno appunto
contemporaneamente la densità cioè i
robot installati per numero di
popolazione di lavoratori più alti del
pianeta
questo significa che quello che si sta
cercando di spiegare che warren burns
dice all'inizio
all'inizio del mio discorso è che molti
tecnofobi sostengono e cioè che nel
futuro solo il 10 per cento degli esseri
umani lavorerà e il 90 per cento sarà
sussidiato questa non è solo un'ipotesi
economicamente insostenibile è
un'ipotesi eticamente mostruosa voi
provate a immaginare un 10 per cento che
parteciperà alla vita civile economica e
il resto dell'umanità in panchina questa
è un'immagine assolutamente terribile e
peraltro non veritiera io sostengo che
chi fa quelle previsioni hanno la stessa
valenza scientifica delle
interpretazioni del calendario maya che
prevedevano la fine del mondo nel 2012
siamo ancora qui per cui evidentemente
c'era qualche previsione sbagliata su
questo tema è fondamentale quello che
dice papà francesco
i nei vangeli gaudium dice il tempo è
superiore allo spazio ovvero il futuro è
conseguenza del presente è anche un
richiamo a tutti i gruppi dirigenti
occupatevi meno di spazio e di potere
occupatevi un po di più di futuro ma il
tempo è superiore allo spazio significa
che ciò che sarà il futuro dipende da
ciò che faremo oggi domani con le nostre
azioni e ciò che siamo capaci di fare
ci sono tantissime statistiche chi dice
che si perderanno
totti milioni di posti chi se ne
guadagneranno altrettanti in realtà la
sfida è completamente aperta non è
possibile fare un'ipotesi tranne che
immaginare intanto come cosa cambierà il
primo aspetto è che cambia il lavoratore
massa il lavoratore in serie che fa
mansioni brevi e ripetitive non solo
operai e anche impiegatizie attenzione
quello che cada prima il primo lavoro
che si cancella non è solo il lavoro
meno qualificato operaio è il lavoro
impiegatizio ripetitivo il primo ad
essere sostituito è proprio quello
impiegatizio ripetitivo la manualità ben
ibridata con le macchine per fanti è
molto utile in termini di non
sostituibilità l'altro aspetto
fondamentale è che la grande
trasformazione digitale smonta la
rigidità degli spazi e dei tempi di
lavoro noi siamo abituati a lavorare in
quel luogo in quel posto per quelle ore
le otto ore 40 settimanali 1760 ore
l'anno il futuro ci dà tante opportunità
di lavorare in maniera più smart
certo chi deve presidiare una macchina è
diverso ma quanti lavori oggi io
sostengo che lo smart working oggi è
utilizzato al 2 per cento delle sue
potenzialità
io penso che i figli di mia figlia a 9
anni
domani la prossima settimana ne compie
dieci i suoi figli rideranno del fatto
che noi tutte le mattine facciamo un
esodo dalla periferia al centro delle
città e la sera dal centro della città
verso la periferia perché per due p due
terzi del lavoro è completamente inutile
e costoso dal punto di vista ambientale
non concilia la vita con il lavoro e
soprattutto non è utile per la
produttività e per questo serviranno
progettisti persone capaci di
ridisegnare disegnare i luoghi di lavoro
e ripensare in qualche modo gli orari
il tema fondamentale crescere le
competenze su in alto vedete quello che
era il manifesto delle unions inglesi il
primo sindacato nato sulla faccia della
terra e la loro rivendicazione era
importante dicevano otto ore di lavoro
lavoravano 12 8 ore di riposo e otto ore
per me ecco questi sono risultati che
solo in parte dal punto di vista
sindacale siamo riusciti a portare a
casa
intanto perché le 8 ore per me sono
ancora una conquista molto importante
perché per come sono organizzati i tempi
di vita e tempi di lavoro
le otto per ore per me rischiano di
essere un miraggio ma su questo sarà
importante concentrarsi perché sarà una
battaglia decisiva
altro aspetto su cui ci sarà
l'innovazione eserciterà degli effetti
completamente this raptim è questo qui
soprattutto in italia noi immaginiamo
due tipi di lavoro il lavoro autonomo e
lavoro dipendente il lavoro che si sta
creando il nuovo lavoro non è né
autonomo e dipendente
negli stati uniti si calcola che questo
nuovo lavoro né autonomo e dipendente e
un terzo e diventerà la metà del mercato
del lavoro degli stati uniti
su questo nuovo lavoro se gli
applichiamo se usiamo le scatole
giuridiche contrattuali sindacali
legislative del lavoro del novecento e
cioè lavoro autonomo e lavoro dipendente
pensate a un lavoratore che lavora con
una piattaforma è una start up
se io gli applico full time lavoro
dipendente tutti i diritti del full time
la start up chiude se io gli applico
tutte le regole del lavoro autonomo
il lavoratore non ha diritti allora
bisogna immaginare tutto un nuovo
sistema di regole e di tutele proprio
per questo nuovo lavoro perché lo
sbaglio più grande a inscatolare il
nuovo lavoro nei vecchi contenitori del
passato e inefficace e inutile non dà
nessuna possibilità per le persone quali
sono dicevo i lavoratori i lavori che
crescono si vedono appunto le mansioni
ripetitive lo dice anche l'in app sono
quelle che si stanno sostanzialmente
sostituendo progressivamente dalle
macchine questo grafico è quello che ha
spaventato l'umanità
non so se chi di voi lo conosce è un
grafico del world economic forum in alto
è la curva di quanto costa per ora
all'utilizzo di un robot e in basso la
grafico della
del costo orario di un lavoratore non so
se si vede bene ma nel 2015 si
incrociano significa che il costo di un
robot orario il costo di un lavoratore è
simile e da quell'incrocio sono è nato e
le teorie più buffe come quella di bill
gates
tassiamo i robot provate a immaginare
l'italia l'italia è un paese che su 5
milioni di imprenditori ed imprese
4 non dicono robot dicono che internet è
inutile che non hanno nessun sito web
pensate se quelle aziende che hanno
assoluto bisogno di innovazione
tecnologia gli introduce addirittura una
tassa nel nell'introduzione di robot
significa marginalizzarli e fargli
perdere sempre più terreno
quale è la sostanza di questo
ragionamento è che si dice l'innovazione
oggi e disruption e come un'onda che
arriva in qualche modo cannes si
cancella le vecchie mansioni e le
vecchie tecnologie
esiste un periodo di tempo non fisso non
è predeterminato dal fato esiste un
periodo di tempo in cui si compenserà
più o meno ciò che si distrugge compresa
l'occupazione e da che cosa dipende
quanto sarà compensato il vecchio lavoro
con il nuovo e quanto tempo durerà il
periodo di compensazione dipende da ciò
che farai in anticipo da ciò che
riuscirai a costruire nell'impresa nelle
forze sindacali nel territorio nella
provincia nella regione in modo che ci
si prepari a questo cambiamento
lo dico perché è un tema che in italia
si sta giocando molto poco
noi abbiamo sappiamo dal world economic
forum che il 65 per cento dei bambini
che oggi frequentano le elementari
faranno un lavoro di cui oggi non
conosciamo neanche il nome
in italia il 20 per cento degli studenti
universitari stanno studiando per delle
materie per alcuni lavori che al momento
della laurea non esisteranno più
per fortuna il 15 per cento sta
studiando per lavori che oggi non
esistono e che esisteranno solo il
futuro
questo è fondamentale perché significa
fare cose sarà quello che è stato fatto
in germania in germania angela merkel ha
fatto il patto per la scuola digitale ea
ristrutturato tutta la istruzione
primaria ripartendo dalle competenze
digitali noi per quello pensiamo che sia
fondamentale il diritto soggettivo alla
formazione il guaio delle ragazze i
ragazzi italiani e che rispetto ai loro
colleghi europei smettono di studiare
prima iniziano a lavorare più tardi e
quando iniziano a lavorare si interrompe
completamente il loro rapporto con la
formazione per reggere il passo di
queste sfide tecnologiche
bisogna assolutamente fare in modo che
le persone lungo tutta la vita
lavorativa abbiano formazione di qualità
per questo noi non siamo pronti ma
dobbiamo immaginare di sgombrare tutta
la retorica che c'è contro
l'intelligenza artificiale le macchine
il block chain
in realtà se ci pensiamo anche la
tecnologia che ci appare più
disumanizzante è proprio quella che ci
fa riflettere di più su quella che è la
nostra umanità
tutto ciò che le macchine ci toglieranno
lavori faticosi pensate all'utilizzo
degli esoscheletri lavori ripetitivi nei
lavori ripetitive le persone non si
realizzano
questo ci fa riflettere su qual è il
nostro contributo insostituibile e per
questo sarà fondamentale avere gruppi
dirigenti con una visione capace di
immaginare qual è la traiettoria dello
sviluppo e costruire occasioni di lavoro
che esaltino appunto la parte
imbattibile degli esseri umani che
l'umanità
nessun un algoritmo di intelligenza
artificiale è capace di pensiero
strategico
nessuna algoritmo di intelligenza
artificiale capace di pensiero critico
di pensiero laterale e questo invece è
proprio la nostra capacità probabilmente
in questa gara che non dobbiamo fare non
contro le macchine ma insieme alle
macchine
dobbiamo riscoprire qual è il nostro
valore e io per questo penso che il
lavoro grazie alle tecnologie sebbene
utilizzate innanzitutto la tecnologia
non è oggettiva non è bene o male la
profilazione dati può essere utilizzate
per governare i cittadini come fanno in
cina o per salvare vite umane come fa la
sanità americana la techno
non si sa bene utilizzata nel lavoro può
aiutare a rendere la vita in qualche
modo il lavoro nella vie la vita più
concilianti e può rendere il lavoro più
umanizzato io per questo parlo di una
grande sfida che può essere il lavoro
del futuro e può essere una sfida punta
umanità aumentata grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]